so today we are going to talk about from
self-taught program to job are the
reason why we are talking about that is
because free code camp is actually the
platform where people start to start
learning to code but also to get a job
in a completely new industry completely
different industry that they are used to
use to be or use to to work and we were
asked many times to talk about our
experience and we both came practically
from nothing to a program a job and
that's why we are talking about it today
and we will have a question-and-answer
session afterwards so feel free to ask
everything you'd like yes just a short
road map what we gonna cover we will
talk about our life before we will talk
about the learning process we will talk
about applying for jobs we will talk
about working at the new company then
this year explain the main qualities and
actions to get a job actually and the
last the last thing will be about
motivation because people always ask how
do you stay motivated on the on their
way
so yeah yes let's start with our life
before programming how many of you guys
actually started to program from a
completely different field cool
so like 50 percent something roughly
very nice yeah so you guys know what it
takes to like start with a completely
new set of rules and mindset in my case
it was like I'm student I'm a business
law student I have worked in different
business law firms tax advisory firm
different workshops and also had like
entrepreneurial stuff but most of the
time I was also like nonprofit worker so
most of the time was just student
working and working here just working
and studying my whole life so not really
much programming I had no idea what HTML
was nothing yes
that's that's about me yeah and with his
background in business and such I had a
different background I grew up on a wet
cold mountain in Bergen I was raised by
sheep farmers it was quite miserable at
times but no that's not the real story
but maybe I should control them but I
did grow up in or by wet mountains in
Bergen
it's full of the rainiest cities in
North and Northern Europe it has about
250 days of rain a year so it gets quite
miserable but we strangely enough we
cope and I didn't get raised by sheep
farmers but we have national costumes in
Norway that are mainly made of wool and
just pay special attention to the fact
that these socks are purely made out of
sheep's wool
handcrafted and such so they're always a
pain to put on for these occasions they
go up until like here so that's nice my
background back to childhood I was
always the computer guy in class I
always liked from the first chance I had
with a dad or with a dad working in tech
to you know bash at the keyboard at age
five or something from a Commodore or
Macintosh or something I always found
out they had or early on found out they
had a love for computers I didn't take
it further until then learning HTML
making some websites I had two parents
my father and my mother they got
divorced whenever I was at my dad and I
used to live mainly at my mom's place
he had internet so I could get tutorials
on how to learn HTML print them out go
back to my you know regular home on a
computer but no internet learn how to
make stuff with HTML it was really cool
but then a couple of years later I got a
book Java in 21 days and I was like yes
but I was the kind of person who says I
didn't understand why it said
system.out.print in' I must be a stupid
guy because they can only be math
geniuses understands this is a esoteric
type were writing out and why it makes
some stuff happen and there was no one
there for me to tell me that
take a step back you're not stupid this
is the same friend for everyone in the
beginning and it was the same for me
also in school learning maths it was
easy for me or all courses in school was
easy for me up until the stage where we
had sort of like equations algebra and
stuff and I thought that hey up until
that point I just had to be in class
pay attention barely do homework I did
fine but then once I had to memorize
rules and just apply them I didn't
understand that that was what you were
going to do I thought I had to really
understand what was going on because
that's how it had worked for me up until
that point so all this just to say that
I really had enforced the myth that
programming is for math geniuses only so
I kind of ruled it out from that from
that point on and then skipping ahead a
little bit young adult life instead of
going into computer school which I may
be let's just call it that which I maybe
would have done if I would have not had
this misconception I instead said hey
let's try psychology studies didn't work
out let's try to study philosophy didn't
work out then I kind of prioritized
student life and working instead of
studying and at one point I panicked
realized I couldn't really get a job as
a philosopher so I went to Ireland and
I'm from Norway but I went to Ireland to
work for multinational companies and
eventually all this led to me having a
bit of a burnout I worked in sales tech
support public server public transport
support and so on and didn't really work
jobs I liked I just went there to earn
money and I became a sad panda and I
mean it literally because I became a sad
panda life in Ireland
just working drinking eating whatever I
wanted was not good for me cool yeah now
let's let's go to the learning process
when you start to learn to code it's
like like like this picture here my code
isn't working and I don't know why and
if the code is working I also don't know
why so this was always like when I was
working on something it was always like
this
and I guess it's for most of you like
like that when you started out learning
to code for me I captured my whole
learning experience like in these free
pictures here and the first you see like
github contributions and the second
thing you see like cheesecake and coffee
because that's like super important when
you program a lot and down here that's
actually a one hour before the gym it's
actually in the gym well what I wanted
to tell with that picture is that you
have to are you yeah you have to fit in
or use every every time you get when you
are busy when you have family studying
working you don't have time for learning
to code your whole day so when you have
time like an hour before the gym or
whatever or when you're traveling on the
bus on the train use the time for coding
and as you as you can see here I was
like that's only github I was like
coding
every day like there's the challenge
like hundred days of code forming a
habit so it gets into your body and
that's actually the result and that's
without the freaking curriculum which
also looked like that so many many hours
many many contributions and a lot of
coffee and studying and yeah just
learning to code that's also like from
article as I said before this this this
tool is like vaca time it's like a
plugin for the editor it's it's for free
so you can check how much time you
actually spend on on projects on github
and here what I've tracked like from MIT
what's it like from mid-april April to
mid-july or in July like 250 hours I
spent just coding so that that was down
to like on an average of two hours per
day so just to give you a perspective
how much it can take to learn to program
and to not be frustrated along the way
just put in the hours and what you can
see he also is like I put in or I
created on code pen actually a small
application a homepage they'll actually
come
today I was yeah
time spending coding and till this day
it's like 380 days so that's pretty cool
and what I also wanted to tell you if
that is like to do your own projects
always don't try to follow the
curriculum or whatever tutorial try to
make your own stuff happen and you will
learn much quicker and better in general
so to have it in a nutshell
I put in many hours did a lot of
research not only not only tutorials or
videos or books or whatever try
everything out see what works for you
best and then go with it in my case it
was just many contributions and own
projects and always trust yourself but
I'm going into that later on yeah so
going back to my my misconception that
you had to be a math genius to learn to
program to get out of this burnout and
to get a better life I gradually tried
to do that one project was me in a
partner in Norway we started a company
to provide websites for businesses based
on WordPress we never really took off we
never scaled super high mainly because
we didn't have enough sales but we had a
few customers and at the point we were
thinking I was thinking I was part of
the technical part and my party was part
of the sales and I was thinking we're
doing this stuff and we're just barely
making any margin on offering shared
hosts hosting for customers what if we
could host ourselves and I'd already
been interested in Linux for a while but
you know how it can be with Linux you
you try and you try and you fail and you
try and you fail and you try and then
eventually maybe you make a switch to
Linux which I have but it took a long
while so in that process I knew it was
possible to host yourself so I decided
hey let's try this I tried some
tutorials and I finally had a
breakthrough when I stumble across Linux
Academy and I took apart it was the
first time I was using an online course
to learn math to train myself or to
teach myself something and I managed to
from knowing nothing about hosting
servers just shared hosting to be able
to set up a lamp stack Linux appacha my
sequel and PHP
for hosting for customers professionally
so that was a big AHA for me but I was
still thinking you have to be a math
genius to learn programming figure that
so this picture was to illustrate when I
realized that hey I can learn stuff
online then I thought let's try
programming but it must be hard so let's
try again I tried three house first just
a brush-up HTML and CSS kind tasted a
little bit of JavaScript I thought hey
okay it's cool to learn about functions
and variables and control statements and
stuff but you know one does the real
programming start so I kind of took a
step back and it wasn't until I stumbled
across free code camp about two years
ago now that I realized that all the
stuff that I thought was just the basics
in programming is programming and then
you just have to iterate over the same
things use them in different ways call a
bit more advanced into the language and
design and other topics that are more
like on the architectural or just get in
your fingers and be experienced you know
what it's the best choice for the for
the job and so forth but the basic stay
the same and when I realized that just
imagine after about 30 years or you know
I'm 33 now but I was probably around 30
then but after many years from a kid
thinking that programming was not for me
to finally bursting the bubble and
thinking I can do this I was really
motivated because I really wanted to do
this and I saw it as as a way out of my
misery so then I stuck with free code
camp as Tony I said it can be
challenging and you have to put in a lot
of hours I put in a lot of work at first
as many people do and then I fell out a
little bit I wrote about it at my blog
hello I love koat.com and one of the
things that helped me was to step take a
step back from free code camp read a
book that is actually and I saw it it's
here eloquent JavaScript helped me
personally to get a fresh look at free
code net JavaScript not from free code
camp but from another source
I supplemented with other courses I like
udemy because they have a lot of courses
that you can buy on demand and keep for
life and then I got back into
groove of free code camp yeah so the
book care is not an icon for something
YouTube started doing that's just
because I also used books
yeah and free kool Kamp
when we talking about motivation little
bit later it has been a constant part in
this whole journey just knowing that I
was organizing starting to organize the
freakin local group here for the free
coke app meant that I felt obligated to
make sure I could tell the other people
at the meetup that I had progress is the
last time so this the social aspect was
really helpful as well yeah so after
learning a lot the next step is actually
applying for a job and I think that's
pretty interesting for us because our
stories the stories are pretty yeah
different actually for me just two
pictures here one day from the interview
from the day of the interview and
another picture is also from the meetup
here the reason why I'm putting up those
pictures here just to give you an
impression how I looked when I was
applying for the job but to summarize it
I don't want it to be an employee
actually at I started to Co to become a
freelancer and I was only focused on
projects and meetups I wanted to get to
know people and I wanted to build on
projects and I tried to contribute as
much as possible to anything code
related and literally when I when I when
I did realize there are meetups here in
Vienna it was my first meetup it was
actually the web clerks meetup here and
I was going to everyone and like hi I'm
Daniel I'm a program a beginner I don't
know a lot but another little thing yeah
do you have an open source project and
if yes can a contribute and I was like
going to everyone like hi I'm Daniel can
I contribute and then like you know
everybody and then I met one guy
actually Benny and he said of course
here I had I have an open source project
we can like work on it together and then
we we met for weeks and months and like
after I don't know four to five months
he was like yeah or my company is
looking
looking for a developer we have like a
job offer we want to work with me yeah
of course
and that's actually it how I got the job
of course there was like an interview
and he was asking questions he was like
yeah show me your project tell me a
little bit of would you tell me a little
bit about your your your stack why do
you want to do it that way
etc but nothing really hard no hard
questions and what I want to tell you
here is for me up the absolute key here
was to build a relationship to network
and get into a job over a guy already
knew that's like super powerful because
he can refer me and also like from the
employer side he's like okay he has
already worked with one of my employees
so he has to have something good and he
tried that employer already trusts the
other employee so that was like a big
plus and that's actually for me it was
actually pretty easy so on your side I
want to do a little bit different route
back to my work I'm having a company in
Norway selling websites to companies I
did that and I also supplemented with
some freelance work mainly a very simple
WordPress based tasks a lot of
repetitive stuff didn't like it all so
much but that was in the face that I was
starting to learn to code so as I
learned to code I could do more code
related stuff one of the criterias for
me it's looking for a job I was in this
freelance days but I want to something
full time because the freelance was
sporadic or not stable enough income for
me
but I wanted to look for a full-time job
and it had to be english-speaking
because my German is not so good if they
would allow German they would have to be
really kind people and then I focused on
continuing to organize the meet-up that
I learned here and I also organized now
it must be last year maybe no to school
in the summer
I contacted node.js speed up and said
hey can we do something so I helped do
that I also helped hacker X which is
speed lighting for developers have their
first first two events and Vienna
service
for them and I'm also the ambassador for
a correct now for ambassador no what's
it called angel hack even though they
haven't had something here yet I hope
they will come soon so all these things
I could put on my resume and I was
active and I was in the community and I
like to engage and it was also something
I could benefit from when searching for
jobs I didn't feel when I started to
send applications around April that I
had enough portfolio stuff and I really
did that just had a couple of things
from free code camp and I had something
you know when you're forking stuff from
github and you just put him down some
lines in a new idea thing and stuff so
that it looked like it was busy but it
wasn't really much to github either but
I said hey let's just try to apply
because I have to apply and get a get a
job let's see how this goes I just had
the approach that I would just send us
as many applications as I as I could
not super money but definitely over 50
applications in the span of April to
August 50 55 zero but it's it doesn't
have to be hard like you can go on sites
I also included remote work so I can go
on sighs like we work with more clear
calm and others for remote work find you
know the ones that are looking go to
their site you know copy/paste into the
forum have a little bit of a application
letter if you want to be personal and so
on so it doesn't have to take so much
time so I just try to make it as
streamlined as possible and of course
apply if I really like the job ad I also
had a rule of it was if I was in Delft
either if I liked a job or not
or if the job said mid to senior and I
was like huh or they had this list of
requirements and I had like maybe 10%
I'd be like okay you know what you can
think as much as you want but if you
don't apply your lemonho-- so I just
made the rule I'll apply if I'm in doubt
so a lot of applications I had two
rounds one round with a plain
application black and white like it
learned in school you should list your
experience you should list your school
experience and chronologically
everything boring plain straightforward
didn't work so well so I said okay
let me rephrase things a little bit
present myself as an already developer
and not down sell myself so I changed
some wording and presented myself
and I got a professional-looking
template with a picture and some colors
and stuff and really nice layout design
and that really helps because after just
the first few applications I got
feedback it ended up that I got the job
that was the first interview I went to
but it took them probably two months or
something to offer me the job so in the
meantime I had I think four other
interviews and the interview also has
Dalia said for me it wasn't so technical
it was more that they saw that I had the
ability to learn that I could talk about
the choices I had made in terms of the
frameworks and technologies I was using
for my projects when I was learning that
I was not just following along but was
reflected about it and I really had
found the passion of coding that I
didn't know I could do until recently so
I think that yeah shine did shine
through yeah yeah I shall take on
working at the new company that's very I
want to keep that very short because it
at first it's it is like it's too much
this is too much this is literally how
are you looking in the new company
because it's like of course of course
you will be overwhelmed because there
are like people are more experienced in
the field you have never worked in of
course what we want to talk about here
is like okay the company is different
every company is different so there is
no what one rule fits all solution here
what's also like important is to keep
always the learning attitude because
people are like way smarter than you
probably or hopefully and you will have
like failures and you you might not know
a lot but with having a learning
attitude everything will work out
perfectly and you can also lean on the
stuff that you learned while learning to
code which was programmer or hopefully
all program is doing their job which is
googling and if you don't know the
answer you Google and you try to figure
it out you open ten tabs you go through
them you find best answer you see if you
learn something hopefully you don't copy
paste everything from
color flow but that is something that is
good that you already have a habit of
and definitely I was also overwhelmed I
had the impostor syndrome I was like I'm
not good enough for this I this they're
gonna fire me after a month oh okay I'm
here I'm still here in a month you're
gonna fire me next month
no I'm still here it's been a year and
I'm still there so I must be do
something this must be doing something
right yeah yeah I think that's mainly it
about our experiences were open for
questions afterwards in terms of working
at the new company but it has definitely
been a challenging ride but joyful and
learning experience and yeah yeah so now
the takeaways I think this is the most
important part of our presentation and
it's also like the last part so feel
free to be or to take to pay attention
to these points because it's like what
we decided is the most important thing
when you start applying for a job or
getting in a new industry and for us it
was like free free points actually it
was like skills ability to learn and
passion yeah yeah this is as I said
condensing down what we found to be the
most important things obviously you have
to have some programming skills you have
to know the job that you're applying for
if you can demonstrate that you have the
ability to learn which is easier when
you can back it up with the free code
camp process or some progress or
something like that that's really
helpful every employer is different some
companies they don't really care so much
about the ability to learn or the
passion they want someone with years of
experience dependable etc for every
company it's different but in our
experience we found that the companies
that do accommodate and do focus on
these three things
are the ones that you're most likely to
get a job at and passion as well is
something I just want to touch on
because I know that a lot of developers
of people wanting to get into
programming
it doesn't necessarily do it because
they love to do it it's perfectly fine
if you
the idea that you want to change a
career either for economic reasons or
because you want to do something
different and you've seen that
programming could be a look at your
field or you could have some freedom etc
so you don't have to have the passion is
what I'm going to get at but we found
that it helps and if you can communicate
somehow some aspects of programming
development etc or the culture whatever
that you like and you can get it across
in an interview it helps yeah so
basically you have to find a balance
between your skills and your ability to
learn and your passion so it has to be
in balance or you have to provide
something at least to convince the
future employer yeah so what are they
concrete actions that you can take to
get a job and for or we concluded that
the most important things here are
portfolio Network working and promoting
yourself and actually showing up it's
like that's like maybe it might be the
hardest thing actually to do so yeah you
want to take on yeah building a
portfolio and get some contributions I
had a phone interview with a company and
I was he tried he sounded like he had a
little bit more expectations than what I
had give tried to give across in my
resume so I was kind of like saying
don't play it a little bit maybe I
shouldn't have but I did and he was
commenting oh yeah but you have so much
stuff when you get to profile I was like
yeah and I was thinking afterwards wow
the power of just having something on
your github profile I'm not saying you
should just put something that that's
crap and just hope that it helps but if
you have something on github that is
your earnest effort to learn and you're
active and you're contributing you're
trying to change something in the readme
of a big open source projects that's
also fine if you can like get a taste
for the field all that helps also from
reading articles or hearing experiences
from others and most hiring managers
will not read your code they might skim
a little bit and then they skip the rest
because not everyone loves reading other
people's code all day long
as for the networking and promoting
yourself there also is a point that is
also supposed to cover the aspect of
sending out your resumes so you don't
have to network you don't have to go out
there and say hey hey hey if you if
you're not the person that want to don't
feel comfortable doing that that's fine
but then you make sure you send out
resumes and applications and the job of
the application I found is to get
yourself an interview
so again just if in doubt just send out
applications and they're the job of
sending those applications is so you get
invited to an interview so keep that in
mind and in the interview it's the job
of the prospective employer to decide
whether or not you're fit for the
company if I had to break it down to one
single important feature it's like the
portfolio because I've been asked about
show me something
not just from the employer future
employer just friends whoever everybody
just wants to see something and you
should at least be able to show them
something and as Robert said before I
totally agree on that
like just showing that you're that you
did something at github is incredibly
powerful it looks amazing and no but
nobody really dives into the code and
says ah that's like that's not good
so yeah that's it that's it for my side
only concrete actions yeah the last last
point here motivation because we've been
asked many many times how to stay
motivated and we summarized it in three
points here ask yourself why develop a
habit and trust yourself do you want to
start yeah for me the wire was obvious I
realized I had a passion for code and I
didn't think I would never be able to
program so that was kind of just I got
for free and the habit was using free
code camp with the points and the
structure it's really nice to know that
you have a progression towards something
certificate or portfolio projects etc
and it also helped us I mentioned
earlier to come to especially the free
code camp meetup so I was you know had
the social incentive
say yeah okay pushing myself a little
bit further because I wanted to finish
the calculator for example until the
next meetup because if I talked about at
the previous made-up that I was working
on it I should maybe have it finished by
the next time I see the same people yeah
and yeah it's easy to dock yourself but
you kind of just have to push through it
regardless for me with not feeling I had
enough portfolio projects to apply I
just apply it anyways so you kind of
have to push yourself a little bit to to
continue on yeah I think it's incredibly
important to ask yourself why and always
remind yourself why you are on that path
always because you will have failures
you will have setbacks and then it's
important to remind yourself why you
actually on that path and just just look
at the scene here right now we have like
Friday evening you could be at the bar
drinking with friends we all have like
other things to do but you are here
everybody is here actually learning or
connecting or networking so you are
already here and you know why you're
here
and that's also like with the trust
yourself part here it's it can be
incredible difficult to try to start a
new journey in a new industry people are
doubting you you keep having rejection
and failures as he said before like 50
times applying 50 times in previous
chops I was also like applying 40 50
times that's normal but it's like or
maybe it is no I don't know but it's
incredible hard it's like rejection
people that don't even read your your
application and that can be really hard
so don't be frustrated or don't give up
on that because I know some people here
are applying always and they're getting
rejected and that's just part of the
equation that's just the part don't be
frustrated if that happens and yeah yeah
like the guy here if the startup he's
also here he's here he's motivated he
has passion for his startup so that's
that's my point on a motivation trust
yourself and not only the progress or
the process is incredible hard but also
like people
family like people always telling you
stay on your path stay on your like for
me my family expected me to be a lawyer
and my grandmother was like ah nice a
lawyer and now I'm telling her like I'm
programming and she was and she's like
what is programming is there like
Gameboy playing or what what is that she
doesn't really see that that's difficult
and that's opportunities here so that's
also like incredible or it can be
incredible tough so yeah just look out
for that and yes stay motivated on the
way do you have anything to add no no I
think you said it beautifully yeah yeah
motivation is key is key yeah if you
have any questions feel free to ask
about motivation yeah we want to make
sure that we have on record a big thanks
to freako camp both the local group here
which consists of everyone here that
keep coming in also the new faces that
maybe also want to keep coming and to
Quincy Larson's work at starting a frico
camp torgue a couple of years ago and
how helpful it has been for us it's
definitely not sure we would have had
the same path to getting a job if we
didn't have free coca absolutely totally
agree on that
very good platform yes so for to that
yeah this is if you want to so almost
thanks for us we have contact details
and we also have a half of an
announcement in the next slide but you
can contact Danielle at Twitter github
and his web site other places as well
same goes for me and as for the
announcement
we're so inspired by our journey to
becoming full-time developers that we
started a line and organization to help
others do the same
it's really in the study phases if you
go to developers writing I just put it
up on a server today and it just says
developers writing there's nothing there
and we have a gmail address but it will
be changed eventually but for now keep
us in mind I will also link it as since
we are organizing free code camp this
local group will keep mentioning it it
if people are interested the purpose is
to
support programmers in general and
provide provide a platform of exchange
it's actually what we have been doing
for the last month and years even years
but with a legal framework so and we are
not like we are not tied to the free
kool Kamp brand so we can do much more
and we also want to explore more so you
can expect many nice things to have him
yeah but and we also want to try and try
out ways to help others go from learn to
code to get a job so we have some ideas
and we'll play around with some stuff
and his people want to get involved it's
an organization you can become a member
and yeah yeah also if you if you want to
contribute and as you seen before when
we talking about getting a job it's like
contributing can be very can be very
valuable if you want to help out or
something or contribute feel free to
just get in touch and yeah we'll find
something yes thank you
thank you
[Applause]